صهيب ما ابرز تطورات في اليوم الثالث من
عمليه طوفان الاقصى ما زالت المعارك
مستمره بطبيعه الحال التركيز الان يدور في
شكلين من اشكال المعارك الشكل الاول هو
القتال المباشر من مسافات قريبه للغايه في
مواقع في غلاف غزه ونتحدث تحديدا عن منطقه
زيكيم المناطق الشماليه وايضا المناطق
الشماليه الشرقيه سديروت ونتفه عسرا في
هذه المناطق هذه المستوطنات يتركز
المقاتلون هناك وتتركز عمليات القتال
المتواصل اللافت للنظر في هذا الامر ان
كتائب القسام اعلنت بانها زودت مقاتليها
هناك بالذخيره والعتاد هذا يعني ان
المعارك ستدوم اكثر واكثر ايضا الكتائب
اعلنت بانه كان هناك عمليه اخرى ل اقتحام
زكيم هذه القاعده العسكريه وال المستوطنه
المحاذيه لقطاع غزه في المنطقه الشماليه
حوالي كيلو ونصف الى 2 م م في شمالي قطاع
غزه اذا نتحدث عن معارك تتركز الان في
المناطق الشماليه والشماليه الشرقيه من
قطاع غزه طبعا داخل العمق الاسرائيلي داخل
مناطق 48 ونتحدث ايضا عن قصف اسرائيلي
القصف بالقصف قصف متبادل بين قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الجيش الاسرائيلي
وبين المقاومه الفلسطينيه الكتائب قالت
بانها قصفت تل ابيب مطار بن جوريون لاول
مره يقصد بهذا الشكل وهناك حاله من الفوضى
في مطار بن جوريا شاهدناها على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي في مقاطع فيديو انتشرت
بكثافه في حاله الفوضه في مطار بنورين
نتحدث عن قصف كبير جدا وهائل من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي باتجاه مناطق في قطاع غزه
نتحدث عن المئات من الشهداء الذين سقطوا
مجازر ارتكبت حتى هذه اللحظه والاعداد
حصيله اعداد الضحايا الفلسطينيين في
ازدياد في مقابل ان ما زال الجانب
الاسرائيلي يحصي اعداد قتلاه والعدد تجاوز
800 قتيل اسرائيلي حتى هذه اللحظه العمليه
المستمره كتاب القسم قالت انها قصفت تل
ابيب ب بعشرات الصواريخ قصفت مطار بن
جوريون وبطبيعه الحال كل المناطق دون ذلك
نتحدث عن تل ابيب 70 كم ما دون 70 كم كلها
تعرضت لقصف عسقلان ومحيط قطاع غزه
مستوطنات غلاف قطاع غزه كلها تتعرض القصف
اذا ما زلنا في هذه العمليه المستمره
عمليه كتاب القسام طوفان الاقصى ما زالت
مستمره في غلاف غزه مقاتلوها ما زالوا
داخل الاراضي والبلدات والمستوطنات
الاسرائيليه وعمليات القصف الاسرائيلي لا
تزال مستمر بشكل كثيف ولكنها حتى هذه
اللحظه اسرائيل لم تستطع الوصول الى اي من
قيادات الصف الاول في المقاومه الفلسطينيه
هذا يعني ان هذه العمليه وهذه المعركه
ستستمر لاسابيع كما قال وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي في تصريحاته هذا اليوم